ركود فيروس كورونا رسمي
، المكتب الوطني للبحوث الاقتصادية
هو الحكم على
فترات الازدهار الاقتصادي والركود في أمريكا ، حيث وجد
أن أطول توسع في البلاد انتهى في فبراير
وأن الركود لم يسبق له مثيل ، وقد
حدد المكتب الوطني للبحوث الاقتصادية بسرعة
بداية الركود الاقتصادي هناك.
اقتبس من الحجم غير المسبوق
للانخفاض في التوظيف والإنتاج ،
ولم يكن الركود من قبل
غير معتاد على الإطلاق ، فهو ليس صدمة طاقة أو
كارثة طبيعية أو أزمة مالية
لأنه من صنع الإنسان ، تم إغلاق الاقتصاد
عن قصد لإبطاء
انتشار  الفيروس القاتل مع استمرار فترات الركود
قد ينتهي به الأمر إلى أن يكون أحد أعمق
الفوهات التي شهدها الاقتصاد بنسبة 5 في المائة في الربع الأول
مع توقعات
بانكماش يصل إلى 40 في المائة في الربع الثاني وقد يكون
قصيرًا جدًا ، وكان نمو الوظائف في مايو هو الأفضل
في تاريخ الاقتصاديين  أشاروا إلى ما
يسمونه التوظيف الخفي في الاقتصاد وسط
إعادة فتح بطيئة وسجل
التحفيز التحفيزي الملحمي الذي يكاد يكون دعمًا غير محدود  ق
إلى أسواق الائتمان من الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
وتريليونات في المدفوعات
للشركات العاطلين عن العمل والمستهلكين
من الكونجرس